back up broccolini together
professional I don't wanna have to hit
my buzzer yet but now I have to been a
little sick II poo huh well see sick man
I got bronchitis and slip disc so back
to back or is it it's kind of all came
on at once just aw it's just that time
of year for me man you know when the
Lord kind of tests me I feel like you
know like anything could happen let's
see what this little daddy's up to like
things things are going too good for in
the Lord went well let's not get carried
away here
yeah try this on for a little bronc guys
oh that oh that ain't slowly down let me
throw out your back yeah no oh damn oh
you had the black lung I got the hater
man you got to bring that fake [ __ ] a
lot of people like I have bronchitis you
know but really they're just just a
complete nerd you know yeah they just
have a scratchy throat yeah you don't
have a bronchitis you go to Harvard okay
that's different
give allergies yeah you came to work
today with bronchitis I got it all man
so I got the black lung I got the white
lung dude I got the mulatto [ __ ] lung
baby the brown mom I got that Brown lump
that black panther lung
oh yeah I got something man I got
something Hardy um but you seem healthy
man you seem like you're doing pretty
healthy well I mean I'm you know normal
normal health really not like you know
just normal health what about after that
hit a week you had last week man uh that
was pretty high for you yeah really high
really really yeah I don't know where
Road and get this week dude I know where
row probably Saturn or okay Joey yeah
cell yeah that stuff's too strong for
amateur like me but I'm glad you came
sick and all I know the listeners are
let's hit this let's get into this
let's get into a king of the sting
alright first segment is debate club and
a reminder you can send all your
submissions to king of the sting at
gmail.com include the segment title in
the subject and it helps us out if you
type out whatever this subject is so
first one comes in from Fat Tony go Fat
Tony Tony what up what's up boys
Tony from Bellingham Washington Tony got
one for the debate club if you're out
trying to pick up some chicks do you do
better fly-in solo are you doing better
with the wingman you know boys a gang
gang gang gang not that buzz buzz do you
Tony respect I'm not mad at speech here
either
and here was dope though the way he
looks he might be a good wingman yeah
cuz Tony's got that flash like if you
are a if you're a wasp
you know like Brendon then you have to
take a lightning bug with you as a
wingman you know you can't bring the
same thing you are as a wingman I don't
preach I agree you need to separate it
like you and I roll up you look like a
wet rat I look like this big old chubby
bee yeah girls like do I like bees or do
I like rats yeah when I got both also
you don't wanna go down that journey
let's say there's some smoke show at the
bar
you don't just approach it yourself
everything's fun with the homies the
homies can't have none what are we doing
okay so you're saying that going solo
isn't a good idea
no I think it's fun or when you and your
friends can share the experience cuz who
are you gonna tell you know I'm saying
like oh that's true if we experience it
together we Chinese finger cuff a girl
let's go it's fun dude yeah it's fun for
both of us
yeah that's a good don't be selfish yeah
I like a woman yeah if she's fitting
like that mitten you know what I'm
saying then and I'll say this that solo
who goes solo to meet women Ted Bundy
yeah you wanna be Ted Bundy yeah oh you
wanna be a good guy yeah yeah yeah a guy
who's out there by himself this is a guy
who got dressed by himself think about
this a man getting dressed by himself oh
I'm gonna go out and meet a woman if
he's a wise fella he pops a few
milligrams of cialis or just takes a
bite off of one of the large or 50
milligram ones and and he's out there
he's mildly a wreck pushing that roofie
to maybe maybe ending in LA I don't know
dude if you're lucky if you're picking
up you know these bootleg dick headers
from India off the internet you know
then you'll probably throw have you know
they'll throw in a few roofies dude if
you just ask them it's a good time I
mean it is you know I think it's more of
a family reunion drug you know if you're
ready to spend time around your family a
roofie could really you just go through
it out of body experience yeah I don't
want to go through that this life alone
I want to share it with someone so
there's a bad [ __ ] at the bar I'm gonna
be like yo deal I just do this let me go
do it together
yeah bebop and rocksteady like the guys
who [ __ ] up Jesse Smollett or whatever
like they didn't want to thing if you
were alone during that whole thing thing
if you're like what am i doing
but you got a party like what are we
doing is like dude we're staging an
attack this can be dope like you're
right like we talk to each other into it
yeah yeah you got a party now that's a
good thing yeah talking somebody into it
cuz otherwise it's that's I think the
primary value of a wingman is their
value to talk help coerce you in the
direction of being confident almost like
an offensive coordinator yeah we're
[ __ ] I'm like yo get in there put a
thumb in that ass yeah you know you're
like yeah what dude
you're what you're doing sounds very
like I'm much like a crime what I'm
talking about is two nice guys maybe
they just got out of cotillion class or
something nice you know they just saw
matinee I'm talking about two kind of
guys how about two gay guys talk about
to go to matinee with me [ __ ] no I'm not
into that I'm trying to local gay dude
that's what I'll try to meet a woman bro
so you're not if you're taking me to
matinee at dinner
no woman seem like oh they seem cool
yeah they are oh there's good women out
there who want to see men that have just
come out of matinees and those are the
types of guys that I'm talking about you
know because also you can't be that guy
if you're trying to meet women you can't
be it like a Dave & Buster's by yourself
know if there's kids around
don't be by yourself you're shooting
hoops you're just walking off a handful
of [ __ ] wet tickets and you're so
nervous to talk to a woman it's also
creepy to go to a bar by himself though
like everyone goes to bars with friends
unless you're an alcoholic
put your Ted Bundy yeah I'm saying you
can't just roll a bar by yourself like
whiskey on the rocks huh no friends who
come with you or you're a trucker now
truckers that's a lonely life that's a
lonely life and she's got a sidekick
unless you got that lounge lizard that's
just always there to relieve ya or
she got a little buddy unless you got an
autistic son or something that you're
wheeling back and forth across the
country with you and so I think but
anyway you slice and I think having
doing something with someone is better
than doing something without three so is
this debate club yes it is let's check
out the results before you move on
we need you need a grenade hopper let's
say we're at Dave & Buster's
okay and we're having a few cocktails
maybe we've got the chicken platter
having a grand old time
yeah we got the cookie sandwich right
and then there's just a smoke Shawn like
damn look at her deal but then her big
ugly friends next to her yeah bro you
know exam with that big natalie is a big
Natalie and she says warts are hanging
off her face I'm like bro you got to
take one for the team
yeah that's what being a real friend is
about and I'd be like all right man let
me get over there I'll distract it but
how I do is well unfortunately what
happens with me a lot of times I'm so
nice to Natalie that then the other one
falls in love with me you know let's go
problem to have them then you and
Natalie having a family somewhere off
the interstate or it's the three of you
and you just get needed the best of all
the world if you're into that know you
and Natalie move away and uh you mean
that girl spend that time live that ugly
life no what the what the fans say 62%
agree wingman is the way to go bro solos
the Ted Bundy vibes yes hello is that
Ted Bundy vibe so I'm gonna say look
here lightning bug I appreciate it Gang
Gang man and it seems like wingman is
what you want to do hells yeah be my
wingman lightning what else we got next
up we got an entry from Deana Brendan
Theo hey it's Tiana from Rhode Island
and I got a debate for you rocky or
Rambo me personally I say rocky rocky
for it's got the greatest train montages
of all time but let me know you guys
think okay bang bang Theo I'll see you
March 7th of the chevalier theater love
you guys rocking them titties hey gang
and I'll see you March 7th at the cheval
Year theater as you mentioned and that's
not sold out yet and that's in Boston
Austin Boston gotcha uh was rocky or
Rambo both classics it's the same guy in
it but one has box um it's on the other
has a k47
is it the same guy the same movie same
guy same
director different list though he's a
different list I feel like in Rambo the
rod I would say if you're gonna drug
test the man in Rambo he's on more
steroids okay he's probably unsung yes
Jack when she's honest one other oh dad
go win stall the whole Gold's Gym vibe
okay yeah whatever he's on that Gold's
Gym stat also here's the other thing
that bothers me about rocky that [ __ ]
the the great bill bird pointed out that
[ __ ] has a statue in Philly
based on a fictional character box and
character they're beautiful
way better boxers real boxers they don't
have a statue in Philly I don't know if
there's bad boxers he didn't have as
many opportunities as some of these
other boxers because he was white at the
time boxing become a completely black
sport you know and first of all rocky
though the guy I mean the movies I don't
think do justice to the fighter I mean
the movies he fought the same black guy
three times he bought that he fought
that German guy who couldn't even talk
but a little Russian yeah yeah that guy
who was that guy Ivan Drago yeah that's
not even a name that's a couple of
sounds in a row and so he fought that
guy you know
Rambo served in Vietnam John Rambo
pretty served in Vietnam brother yeah
well they're [ __ ] welcome how's this a
debate yeah did a terrace send this in
John Rambo bro did steroids have bought
a gun and a knife yeah you can a [ __ ]
sword Pacey yeah dude yeah that's brave
bro I've been on steroids you think I'm
buying guns dude no I'm hitting the gym
bro like I'm lame booooo not Rambo he's
fighting for your freedom yeah this is
Rambo all [ __ ] day
dude most of us do stairways to go to
the gym he does stairways to go to war
and he does steroids to defend your
freedom what do they say the audience
says 64% says rocky the [ __ ] now rocky
Dennis okay if you're gonna say rocky
Dennis from that movie mas came ask have
you seen that movie can we pull up a
picture of rocky Dennis
now we're talking about Rocky verse
Rambo then I'm that's a real dude right
yeah that's a real do man you did not
want to be in a headbutt contest with
that job you heard Linda look I've met
the head-butting champion in the world
that ain't him but that guy
second or third place I got could wear
that silver medallion and I'll say this
now raakhi verse Rambo this dude has a
way bigger heart and I think in John
Rambo so if we're talking serious first
names rocky rocky Dennis yeah damn look
at rocky dead is he still alive there's
no way he passed away yeah for sure but
uh he yeah and he almost I used to joke
he looks like Amy Schumer a little bit
if you go rocky Dennis first Rambo then
then on that one I'm gonna go with rocky
Dennis rocky Dennis all day yeah so
Rambo over rocky the fighter and for me
rocky Dennis over Rambo the Vietnam
veteran cosign that alright number three
we've got from summer Lynn hey Brendan
hey Theo okay questions girls at the gym
the ones that walk in looking gorgeous
with full makeup and don't break a sweat
are the girls that get in there and get
dirty and dripping sweat off their nose
and drenched when they leave knowing
which ones your choice buzz buzz buzz
buzz at the end was Bud silver foxy look
here that flush she also photo shoot her
she flushed the toilet let's hear that
again we don't know if it says shitty it
looks like a number one knows she
straight hold on oh no she's straining
bro dropping that I do sir nobody she's
wrong with that she went like this hold
on let's make sure that was but see how
she went like this she went oh play the
last ten seconds give us a little bit of
a dirty trick I'm dirty dripping sweat
getting nitty-gritty which is your
choice see that see this
that's droplets bro sir dude she had
that closure bro she chose a sand of all
bruh that's a Jonathan Papelbon right
there at the end
Rivera baby when you pinch that [ __ ]
Lynch bro me that thing's hanging and
you [ __ ] caught it enter the Sandman
oh wow dude
light right there dude the question was
so obviously she likes the nitty-gritty
girls who get down
listen I don't want my girl dead left in
400 pounds coming home with those
[ __ ] cows hands jacking off my dick
yeah like yeah think about that stuff
man I don't mind the girl who's hot as
[ __ ] and just stares everyone else while
they're doing work with the blood ass I
mean look I'm never you got to think
about it yeah you don't want chalk all
over your dick you want chalk on the
back you're here
I would buy chalk on my back our hair
but I don't want someone just yeah I
don't want anybody jerking me off
besides me first of all I don't care if
it's my wife or anybody handjobs do suck
yeah nobody's jerking me off dude I'm an
adult but now imagine that your dicks
basically the [ __ ] gym bar you know
I'm saying yeah and she has those
calluses on your hands oh yeah I don't
want that I don't want some girl who's
gonna try to you know just rip my dick
off on accident at the house they don't
want to power clean your nuts I'll take
that look for me I'll go with that I'll
take that that drippy Tiffany over that
Fancy Nancy any day of the week bro oh
really drippy Tiffany I'll take drippy
Tiffany over Fancy Nancy because at
least your feet if ax knees out there
puttin in work she's a real woman is she
no there was this chick that yeah that
used to always brag about banging Dane
Cook actually all the time and she was
always at the gym and she never busted a
sweat man and she seemed like a real
good though huh
does she look good though she looked
good here's when she looked good she
looked good the first year I saw her but
after that when I realized that you know
she seemed she'll says she started to
look more like just like a real just
unhappy girl you know like this was her
whole life you know hang out at the gym
time I [ __ ] Dane Cook yeah then I'd
do it it go yeah so I like that I like a
little I like a girl that has a foreign
accent who you can't even understand
them that's what I like in the gym yeah
playing outside
no problem peds maybe they're shooting
it straight into their tongue I don't
care you know I don't want that girl
though that has like hair on her back
and I gotta shave her back yeah I don't
want that I also don't want the girl
who's way more shredded than I am
we can see the veins that are oh yeah
neck she has that GTO hi no blood she's
a group down her [ __ ] no I'm saying
yeah and her vagina just wants to thumb
wrestle it doesn't want you to
a lot of vaginas yeah it looks like
they're trying to hand you something
yeah yeah I don't like you're handing
out pamphlets you know I want that I'll
probably take the girl there's a happy
medium there but for this I will say the
girl that looks hot but doesn't do [ __ ]
yeah I'll take drippy Tiffany over
Francie Nancy any day of the week and
75% of the audience agrees drippy
Tiffany go ahead get you that girl with
the dick in the front with calcified
hands what for - no I did it you went
for Francie Nancy I went for big titty
Becky in the back oh you did yeah you
were for the pretty one yeah oh wow
yeah he's just I [ __ ] it order is
shakes yeah just thirsty as [ __ ] your
dick I'm just in that room I'm like
looking around I want that alright then
they have the headphones on you can see
well that's so worse they have the beats
by dre oh oh and the hairs all perfect
then they have the Lululemon on that ass
is just doodoos beaten by dre a lot of
those women are probably escorts
actually beaten that's true by a rapper
- and are actually just you know their
only job is to work out during the
daytime
we're bought by Kraft yeah but Crawford
Jackie off amen brother
alright last one for a debate club all
right yeah
Brandon question for y'all 94 head bro
Jenna make a million dollars a year and
hate your [ __ ] job I'm ready forty
thousand dollars a year
I love what you do big game gang gang
maybe they babe baby babe babe boy see
that son think you can do you can do
both babe King you do both you do what
you say dad and make a million dollars
you don't have to pick one but that
guy's not even his he's in the first one
he's in the passenger seat of a car not
even his car - Corolla that's a toy to
clear out any passivation things might
be tough for ya I know that's what's
going on he's going hard it's middle of
the night and he's acting he wants to
know what's up from King in the sting
there so you say would you I would much
rather make 40 grand doing what I love
than a million [ __ ] hating life yeah
shouldn't be depressed you know me to
spend that money yeah that's a good
point I think but you don't have to
choose as my this is my thing yeah you
don't have to you can make
what a year what you do doing what you
love
yeah there's there is that I mean from
my own instances man I probably made
$40,000 a year for probably the first
fourteen years of doing stand-up and
that's being generous yeah
and that's probably being generous I
mean I don't know sure you made 702 I'll
win I had twenty-seven thousand dollars
in credit card debt up until about four
years ago and then I started paying it
off because I started making better
money yeah but you know an average man I
would say I made probably thirty six
thousand so I think you know you can do
maybe what you love could turn into
something that could be that million
that million dollar deal you know but I
mean what are you doing with I mean what
is that Milly are you doing something
dirty or you hide you know are you
selling gold to people that come Blood
Diamond yeah you sell them blood
diamonds humans like Robert Kraft to get
your money yeah you and that yeah what
are you doing man you caught up in the
dark arts for that million yeah I don't
want to be in the dirt I don't want that
stress like if you put me in the Hells
Angels pay me a million dollars and just
stressed out all the goddamn time I
don't need that in my life man yeah I
really make 40,000 living the dream but
if you hard to be stressed on one of
those motorbikes you get a motorbike if
you're in there dude you get a motorbike
but you gotta [ __ ] collect [ __ ]
Billy G's money for him you don't know
that's a badass you got a flex on people
click money dude I could see you doing
this no not for me
really no cuz I'm too nice of a person
so if I went to the house and he's like
no please I have kids man I just pay for
daycare like I [ __ ] you man come back
next week and I can't do that yeah
the Hells Angels don't work like that's
true you gotta yeah you have to really
cuz yeah you have to kill that person or
summer at least drop his pinkie up yeah
not for me bro yeah his question was Oh
so I'd much rather if if it's black and
white I'd rather make 40,000 you're
doing some I love ya and I think I would
go with that to a million and sad worked
in a goddamn cubicle or well I didn't
[ __ ] flash lights
53% say they would have took the million
dollars doing something I hate maybe
spend it on their free time I guess now
you work in 70 hours a week making a
million what are we doing here there's a
lot that goes into that I mean and I
guess you could try to do both maybe you
do both but then are you gonna get
acclimated to having that million when
once you get to 40,000 you
not gonna be you're gonna then be
uncomfortable because you got acclimated
you know well I don't think there's an
acclimate having little blankets and
everything yeah I think they were saying
you're making a million now you get a
switch and make be happy and get 40
right you can go down to the pass like
you're just normally can't go it this
way there's a lot that goes into it yeah
you don't want to end up like that man
from Simpsons animation show where they
have a Flanders know that millionaire
man
Oh mr. burns yes or Scrooge McDuck for
that matter
yeah Scrooge McDuck you know we don't
have any children of his own he has his
nephews you never know who their mother
is the family seems out of sorts gonna
[ __ ] up his coins and if to wear a
top hat Oh God
what else alright that does it for
debate club this week moving on to rip
my drip and this first one I believe was
actually a photo taken by Brendan it's a
friend of your guys's
mr. Joe Rogan at the Hollywood improv so
yeah he showed up in this thing but to
Joe's credit he's coming from a 90's
party it's coming from a 90's party
themed party
we're in New Jersey I don't know but he
looks like a member of khabib training
camp oh yeah that's a khabees camp he
looks like pitbulls like he's like he's
uh it looks like a war it looks like one
of um BJ Armstrong's warm-up jerseys
looks like pit bulls he looks like you
straight off the set of Royal Tenenbaums
yeah ben stiller steroid brother that's
bro joke and right there uh yeah it
looks like I'll sell you the best
winstrol at Gould yeah I guess syringes
in his back he look like you literally
he'll pop three humming you at the mote
and just see which one kind of activates
your skin the best yeah I definitely see
looks like the guy you go to if you want
to pass the drug test
we dog on the street they call mr. Pico
definitely seems like he seems like that
school bus driver
that's just driving everybody straight
to the gym even if they want to go home
yeah your after-school activities are
the gym that's it yeah it looks like
whenever you see him you ask how many
pushups you can do dude in the fanny
pack he has extra triceps in the fanny
pack
it's definitely a rare it's definitely a
rare uniform for him I've never seen him
that uniform yeah I mean it's just not
his style arias though they had the
match and red shoes I couldn't stop
laughing different party was it did he
reference it during a set yeah yeah he
told everyone what's going on well party
was it then he crushed the crowd what
then he went to a memento 94 nineties
thing party for with it with his wife
she dressed up in the 90s dude r.i.p
Billy conforto I went to a crawfish boil
one time with Billy conforto and he's
from the West Bank in New Orleans which
is based like a little bit of New Jersey
right on the edge in New Orleans on the
swamp and they had a whole family of
four and they were all wearing these at
the party Tannenbaum style yeah and they
were it was not like a joke it was like
oh we all got this yeah that's kind of
we got this status net
yeah they had two kids and the wife is
always weird when the family's all
dressed up is the same yeah it's always
a weird vibe yeah right it's yeah it's
kind of it has that a Stockholm Syndrome
we kind of thing it just gives me bad
vibes yeah we're a mean what if that's
the ultimate sign of teamwork man you
might be right maybe I'm just not a good
team player
no I'm yeah I mean I'm just trying to
think of it a different way like well
you know my promise I'd twins growing up
the names were Raymond Adam and they
were twins and that's why I hate twins
this day because we didn't get along
been brothers no they're my cousins of
our arch-nemesis Ojeda well they're twin
sweet fight on the spot yes whatever we
saw we do scrap my brother would go you
better get ready my girl right
[ __ ] so their name was Raymond
Adam so we'd fight to the death
basically they would always dress the
same always and then we'd be [ __ ]
them up like better I get grass stains
on my shirt I shut the [ __ ] up yeah
Raymond and add I do not see him either
Raymond Adam Ben I see on streets today
yeah yeah Raymond and Adam you mother
plus the same dress the same who are you
I don't look swaggy though I like to is
hilarious I mean look it's still Joe
Rogan under the outfit so you know you
got to say you got a dope and with the
fanny pack and why'd you post them up
for rip my drift then well cuz it's dope
I see a minute
like sometimes my trip you don't have to
the rib doesn't have to be too bad
ya know it's like the toughest member
khabib team he does and why was it hallo
it's not even Halloween no what were
they dressed enough I don't know 90s
party I thought there well you know just
sometimes they do not this themes yeah
yeah that's true what else do we got
next up we got a fan submission for rip
my drip he just turned 24 on Sunday this
is Mark Rivera hold up you say 24:41
okay okay I'm the 24th
dammit man
well is he sleeping in that little box
behind him that's yes alarming me can we
zoom in on that actually please least
his legs don't bow in um yeah well dude
its head downhill skier stance he's that
bunny slope or baby he might be he might
be on the moguls right now and yeah
maybe he's sleeping in a little boxing
huh he's in the moguls of life really
he's on those like moguls and what's his
name Amos Marc Marc Marty what up Marc
what up mark up look at the bootcut
jeans those are the booty boot boots
wait a minute whole club looking at Marc
he looks like that redneck Big Pun and
the Terror Squad member oh yeah dude he
looks like medium Joe um yeah Marc is
definitely I like it he's got that news
he kind of vibe if you ever seen the
Newsies he's got that Newsies cap on
he's got that henry winkler he looks he
looks like the guy who can get you
anything in prison you know I'm saying
looks like he's the your go-to guy when
you first get to prison like you got a
run [ __ ] by him like Brooks is here boy
he looks friendly as [ __ ] now his place
is a hot mess that one-bedroom apartment
they living is a hot mess looks a little
out of order you think what's back there
what's up what so what's on is uh the
unit the cage right there what's on
there looks like we had a toothbrush not
used of air freshener toilet paper roll
boil it oh yeah well that's that there
might be a human that's all human stuff
that's I'm saying he rests in that
little domicile
he's like the [ __ ] from Pope
out of his costume yeah he I mean look
man those jeans he's got that bunny
slope kind of uh you know he likes to
he's that downhill Jean boy you know it
looks like he's kind of got that
downhill slide going but look he also
has that sort of nineteen fifties I
don't get a 1955 from I get I get
Brett's I get that he's gonna [ __ ] dude
he looks like he knows the best
restaurants in LA yeah like he makes
that list for the most authentic food in
LA yeah right ten thousand restaurants
they made a list for you yeah mark looks
like a real list maker you know looks I
take pictures of all his meals yeah he
looks like the bet like he knows exactly
where to get some good paint yeah he
looks like the friendliest taxi driver
in the world yeah it looks like he has a
friend that's a taxidermist but he
forgives him for doing it that belt this
goes hard in the paint too my belt is
doing work oh that belt is a belt like
this yeah that belt is a happy birthday
to have belt is it his birthday to say
oh it's his birthday happy birthday
brother
yeah man that belt is velh baby do go go
get yourself a full [ __ ] pie from your
favorite spot and just do work man I say
you look enjoy yourself it's your
birthday baby boy you look healthy looks
like a fudge sundae yep you look like
about maybe five eleven I can't tell he
looks like he's making Ruby fudge right
you know fudge you know fudge boy shiny
now like go hit up fudge hit up fudge
fudge man and he got that paint fudge
might have a boyfriend what else we got
next up from the Oscars this past
weekend this is a Billy Porter this that
Men's Wearhouse fine is Miss Amelia
brody'll yeah he looks like God dog
Jesus Christmas man Roger Ella
it looks like Tim Burton's little
chocolate side this looks like Tim
Burton's nightmare yeah I mean this is
obviously just a reach for attention but
also it's the Oscars so you know people
dress glam and they do this sort of deal
you know I want to know who he's got
holding that thing up from the inside
there's man probably
his sidepiece probably hey [ __ ] got a
job for you couple twinks down there a
couple 20 22 the one to twinks down
there poppin zajonc damn pops he had the
black yeah yeah he looks like the black
lung if you look like him he looks like
dude he he looks like the black longer
around his waist
dude no he looks like the the bad the
[ __ ] villain from Little Mermaid yeah
you know Ursula he looks like a mr.
Ursula yeah he does he look like mr.
Salette and I watched him get cast in
the in the next you know looks like a
Mary Poppins yeah let's say you looks
like the Beatty version of Mary Poppins
listen here's the thing though women can
wear some men's suits and we don't say
[ __ ] so homeboy is like cool move peep
this out I want tuxedo with a dress
attached to it yeah you saw this
attention and also man I mean young
black men have gotten there are a lot
different than black man that I grew up
with how so they're just they're softer
you know like you'll hear a black
Furnham on the other day out here said
he was feeling dizzy Wow God like what
you feeling dizzy bro that's a white
disease man what's next you just you're
not sure how things are going you know
what's next yeah when does it stop you
can't gang bangers your phone ain't
charged when does it stop
but Billy Porter also this is what he
does I think isn't he's a now he's a
kind of a flamboyant man that were true
he's he's a logo for all gay people yeah
like white basketball players have Jerry
West but gay guys have him yeah he's a
gay man isn't he ah just for 5,000 okay
so I'm just saying yet it's not if this
were a straight man that we're doing
this I think it would be more Outland
and be more powerful if a straight man
did yeah and look man I don't look throw
on a skirt every now and then you know
yeah go ahead and cut off your jeans
turn with some George have you asked
cheeks hanging out the bag nuts in the
front do man live a little
yeah mail your dick to Siam do whatever
you want to do if you want um but I
think for what he went for to make a big
splash you're talking about it we're
talking about
everybody was there you go you know did
the right thing but yeah for me it has
that amelia brodie your kind of vibe it
has that sort of it's like a kind of a
butler but also a he looks like the
gayest vampire in the world yeah
like you'll bite you but only if he
knows like what like you know if your
blood is like you know if it's organic
yeah yeah that's gluten-free yeah like
what you've had recently to eat he's
gonna house your diet yeah okay looks
like a very specific vampire take a pic
Eve and pyre yes like a picky vampire
way to go uh Billy Porter you achieve
your goals there man nice outfit what
else we got that does it for this week's
we're at my drip support the podcast
here's an ad oh man do you like uh money
yes I knew you were gonna ask that yeah
I do man but you know what I wanna
invest it's just it's such a hassle it
was such a hassle Robin Hood is an
investing app that lets you buy and sell
stocks ETFs options and Kryptos all
commission free what yeah yeah but they
do they charge like ten dollars for
every trade that's just so much whoa
while other brokerages charge up to ten
dollars for every trade Robin Hood
doesn't charge any Commission fees so
you can trade stocks and keep all of
your profits yeah but do I have to like
put a minimum of like a million dollars
to get started there is no account
minimum deposit needed to get started so
you can start investing at any level
it's the simple intuitive design of
Robin Hood that makes investing easy for
newcomers and experts alike this is
crazy man yeah check it out Robin Hood
has given the listeners of king of the
sting a free stock like Apple Ford
sprint ever heard of them sign up at
Kingston dot Robin Hood DOM sign up at
Kingston Robin Hood dot-com start making
Bank bro that's right on Robin Hood you
can view easy-to-understand charts and
market data and place the trade in just
four taps on your smart phone you can
also view stock collections such as the
hundred most popular with Robin Hood you
can learn how to invest in the market as
you build your portfolio discover new
stocks track your favorite companies and
get custom notifications for price
movements so you never miss the right
moment to invest this is crazy Robin
Hood has given you guys the King and the
sting fans of free stock like Apple Ford
or Sprint wow that's crazy sign up at
King sting dot Robin Hood calm
that's Kingston Robin Hood calm trying
to keep lights on what's up guys it's
one half of the kingdom of thing it's
the sting here and one thing about me is
I like to eat healthy but sometimes it's
such a beast you're busy you got kids
you got a schedule you don't have time
to sit down and plan out a five course
meal don't worry I got you covered yeah
cuz now now there's hellofresh
that's right hello fresh helps you
achieve whatever weight goals you have
your 2019 goals even though it's
February so let's get on it now hello
fresh makes it's so damn easy they have
delicious simple recipes for a healthier
you and delivered right to your door
every week that's right it's enjoyable
it's so damn easy that's the biggest
thing hello fresh make it so easy fresh
pre-measured ingredients easy to follow
steps so you get the perfect amount of
food and it tastes delicious all meals
you ready come together in 30 minutes
max you have 30 minutes to make a
delicious meal look good feel good quick
easy we're talking about hello fresh you
have three plants choose from classic
veggie or family and you can switch them
when you want what else you need get out
of that rut starting fresh starting
clean start eating hello fresh right now
and guess what
with hello fresh go to hello fresh com
use Katz
60 K 80s 60 and you get $20 off your
first three boxes so you get $60 off
yeah that's right 20s off each box go to
hello fresh calm / K 80s 60 cat 60 and
enter promo code cat 60 that's K 80s 60
is the promo code hello fresh get your
sec
yeah support the podcast next up our
newest segment relationship advice
send these in we want we want to solve
your guys's problems the first one is
where can they send it in king of the
sting at gmail.com put relationship
advice in the subject line
yeah what's you guy cuz who doesn't need
relationship from us man you know yeah
look nobody uh yeah yeah I mean we're
[ __ ] so we'll share yeah so don't get
[ __ ]
yeah we've been [ __ ] yeah the first
one comes from lar Kayla out of Indiana
Oh What's Up Girl Gang Gang it's your
girl our Kayla from Indiana yes I have
bad teeth but it's because I grew up
poor I need your relationship advice
every time I talk to a guy and things
have gone pretty well in my opinion my
ass gets kicked right into the bros ohm
and so I asked this previous [ __ ]
what the hell the deal was and he said
that I am too funny so I want to know is
it even possible for a girl to be too
funny to be attractive or dating
material and if so rest in peace me I am
totally screwed i Stan peacemaker well I
like her she doesn't I do I want her as
a friend right now I want to put her in
my pocket as a friend
take her out when you talk somebody do I
have sex with her no but some people's
give off that vibe she gives off that
teddy bear vibe mm-hmm like he's a kid I
took my teddy bear everywhere what's her
name
lark Kayla I'll take lark a lie
everywhere yes
first of all shock lark Kayla was white
just like everybody else was thank you
Lord Kayla for emailing in that's a good
point
markayla it doesn't sound like your
typical white girl yes you're bait and
switching with the name lark Kayla I
want to let you know that upfront yeah
but honey decade I think yeah sometimes
if a girl is too funny it's you know it
it's tougher for a guy if he's if he's
insecure though right because but are
you the one cracking jokes non-stop so
the guy's exhausting he's like okay very
cool man right try and play my video
game shut the [ __ ] up Jerry Seinfeld
that's a good point because that's a
problem for men as well like you know if
you're all like growing up
I used to always just be cracking jokes
all the time and it was and I never had
any dates you know it's like do you feel
like a family function when you're
around your group of friends who aren't
comedians they try to crack jokes all
the time or that's a bit right there I'm
like yeah very cool thank you yeah
sometimes they will yeah I'm just trying
to think of how like if you're the one
cracking jokes I think it's tough for
you know it's kind of it's not a for
some reason other people it just makes
it tougher for them to associate with
you on a level like a relationship level
and says just start that environment
might be dating serious as due to her
under that silly [ __ ] or she busts and
joke's on their dicks let me get him out
she's like damn that's this like should
know when to turn it off yeah yeah
because I look I'm just saying from
experience I've not known when to turn
it off and then not gotten any dates
it's still [ __ ] though I mean maybe
mostly jerking off yeah so but it's
funny I mean it's funny for a little
while to jerk off by yourself but after
you expect it's alarming yeah I find it
funny so I think that's a problem for
men and women so I don't really think
it's like a specific gender issue I just
give off that friendly as vibe though
like I put it right in my circle of
trust right now
yellow you change your name what's name
la Carla let lark Kayla Kayla we'd have
to change that to kk or something like
that ah kk sounds semi racist I'm gonna
go with lark yet a third markayla so
you're so close to your heart lies a
white girl's racist I feel like yeah you
a cult revolt er yeah you gotta steal
their names lark Kayla yes still shocked
lor Kayla's white meat I mean I can't
get over it but I will be your friend
yeah I would be your friend but I think
use your jokes when it's all about
timing
using timing maybe don't clown on his
body when he's about to get his dick
sucked your son like that
but also the clowns are always if you
look at a clown and I'm not calling you
a clown but I'm calling people that are
tend to try and be jovial or screwing
around a lot if we look at clowns clowns
are always by themself and if you're
tired out there right but a little bit
of humor [ __ ] ornery
you know you ever seen a clown with the
entourage yeah never he does his jokes
ain't [ __ ] goes back in Jack's off to
his tears you were seeing a clown with a
bunch of friends
never hurt it's just the way it works
like a movie air bro because usually it
takes a group of people to make some
humour but a clan if he can do it by
himself but then they end up by
themselves because they don't need
anybody else yeah so that's a tough
thing so sometimes yeah if you really
want to meet someone sometimes I think
you will have to kind of tighten it up
and people say well don't don't adjust
yourself and this and that but I'll just
from my experience yeah sometime you got
to tighten it up and just be but only
but you only need to tighten it up if
you're being mean and nasty about it if
you're a good person you're outgoing
you're just funny and the dude can't
hang with it [ __ ] them all so maybe sign
up for an improv class where there's
some dudes in there who are just as
funny probably funnier maybe and maybe
you can start [ __ ] one of them yeah
maybe you're looking bounce ideas off
each other while you're bouncing an ass
- oh wow there you go yeah it's about
yeah it's that's this a dual deal Oh God
all right Clark hey dude that's a point
of the show though clowns are always so
lonely man yep next up for relationship
advice 22-year old math Matthew is
looking pretty I'm 22 some quick
relationship advice sup done ex cheated
on me about a year ago and we recently
started talking again is it worth the
second chance or not let me know depends
if you can get over that [ __ ] did you do
it how do you know she cheat on you I
need some more facts did you catch a
video her again gang banged out by a
bunch of dudes or was it just like a
friend she [ __ ] on the side when she
was drunk what's going on here bro and
if you can get over like a snot big deal
22 everybody [ __ ] you so you do it 22
people be [ __ ] when they're young man
and especially sober like sober sex is
for children I've always said that a
dull - [ __ ] sober it's awkward you know
it's not but if you want to have real
good sober sex you need to be children
both of you and I'll say this as well
can we go back and look at the rat tail
that that fellas hang on oh I didn't see
the rat tail you got a [ __ ] damn good
notice Doug is that a rat tail or is
that a is that a scarf of some sort also
is he in a silk chair is that a rat tail
on the right there I think a pointer on
it right there
that's some talk about that is a dang
rat tail and I know one when I see one
dude and he's got that [ __ ] he's got the
rest of that rat growing on his chin I
love that dude gang bro and he also
looks like a little bit like the guy
from Bohemian Rhapsody
I am salad right milk yeah close though
yeah so yeah I guess he has the same
teeth that's Freddie Mercury I see what
you're saying well you know he just got
that whole vibe man he's got that you
know kind of cool vibe yeah he's got
that Pakistani kind of uh you know wild
church board ah weird I get a Mexican
vibe from but really yeah Danny what's
his name Matthew a lot of Latinos are a
lot of Mexicans are Christian those here
could easily he could easily be Mexican
and that rat tail that rat tails so
Mexican yeah that's definitely Mexicans
are born rat tails my son was born when
he's half is just like a little bit I
cut it off oh wow not up in here buddy
buddy Wow
so we can you can you get a chance hmm I
think a year is too soon I think you
need to give it more time 365 days if
you can't get over after 365 then it's
just not for you I think he can get over
but I don't know if she's changed you
know because she gonna be a cheater man
do nothing once a cheater always a
cheater I'm 22 I think better didn't
cheat at 25 you give her another shot at
28 years she's done ran through the deck
she probably has a man three years later
kids
depends what part of country he's from
Annie's Mexican come on bro three years
she's gone he's no soul mates maybe she
got drunk my night fell on some dick now
if that's that yeah but still I think if
she's in that space you got to give her
more time daddy
you can't be you know I think you just
have to go on about it I think maybe you
know you could always go on a date with
her spend some time with her but I
wouldn't really invest in it heavily
don't franchise tag that yeah
don't franchise tag it dude I would stay
free-agent yeah and and take care of
yourself field a little bit and see let
her come to you cuz she got that risky
biscuit man she's serving that bread all
over town yeah
is that sourdough oh yeah and she's
throwing that thing everywhere and you
want that wheat bread you want that
banana nut nut up
nutty butter yeah what else we got that
does it for this week's relationship
advice so Sam Mosley
help them you know I'm saying I feel
like we're helping too dude I would
never ask you for relationship advice
dude never ask you unless I need a
relationship with like a new face lotion
that's the only time what isn't
naturally that shiny and glossy and
finds way bro I I would never ask you
every relationship advice son dude I
mean I could shoot you a text at 10
o'clock at night just to make sure
you're not jacking off yeah well look
I'm 80 days off pornography right now so
I'm feel you a boy I'm feeling all those
balls are so for I been right brother
he's so right use the memory huh dude
the other day I was standing outside
I'm messing about puts a ladder up right
next to my legs and try to pick my balls
off my body I was like no no no no no
Senor no no no no don't need this yeah
don't pull in to Home Depot
rip them balls right on dude it's very
dangerous but around with this much bull
chandelier yep yep you're packing yeah
yeah oh dude I could call fright now and
[ __ ] semen have a baby yet I could
call you baby you know girl's vagina
right it's not healthy you gotta release
those man it's like anything you know
you crack your knuckles snap your neck
bust nuts but I'm trying to dream I'm
trying to get it out the dreams I'm
riding that nocturnal bus that's what
I'm hunting right yeah that's [ __ ]
you talking about you don't have wet
dreams I don't my body will go you
trying to store not up in here wet dream
really yeah see not everybody gets it
like that so natural I'm trying to get
one I haven't at one years so I'm trying
to get that nocturnal bus you're gonna
bust a nut for a hot second it makes
sense you know weird dude that that
seeming goes straight to mean beard you
can have bronchitis and my back is hurt
yeah yeah you're right it's time for
joke my smoke the first one comes from
Cody chambers he said this was right
before his college graduation I guess
that's the way you want to go into the
world first of all I think this dude
should run for vice president of America
he has everything that I love he has a
above-ground pool within 60 feet of him
which is you can see the
the [ __ ] greatest thing everyone's
laughing sonu sood every time I find the
plane I look at families that haven't I
pray for those families we're seeing
also that bong has an Apple logo on it
no scroll up oh definit there that's
America that's Steve Jobs Oh Steve Jobs
and a-bomb
yes smoking Steve Jobs oh yeah man that
guy he looks like they're straight up
Louis Armstrong a smoking - bro this
ain't no [ __ ] this guy is a plan and
prepared smoker look at that gold base
he's got on that thing he's experienced
him and his boys his frat boys probably
sucked all over that thing oh man I bet
he's four years a slave to that [ __ ]
oh man and I love how the above-ground
pool is also fenced in like not
anybody's getting in here [ __ ]
yeah we paid for this only the family
and friends dude above-ground pool there
is no deep in it's everybody in the same
end
there's no shallow deep there's just me
yes ma'am the same for you yeah dude
there's no stairs to get in either you
just jump right into that [ __ ] and two
months after you get it a bunch of
mosquitoes start living in it - yeah and
then people start getting sick locally
yeah you start pissing in it Oh bro dude
a lot of people will just go back out in
the artists piss right into it right
into it keep it what hi I love an
above-ground pool man - I love exactly
what this guys doing
Oh where'd he graduated from I'm
assuming a Community College he didn't
say okay that's Cody chambers baby joke
my smoke man congratulations baby gang
next up we got Anthony there's a lot
going on here he's doing what the kids
call a DAB what's that smoking straight
weed concentrate and you use a blowtorch
to to heat up a nail and then what bo
it's the home depot of smoking dope yeah
you're like do you does it give you that
crooked [ __ ] I like wise as I like that
cuz he's on 700 milligrams of weed in a
single second well that's math in there
baby but I don't know what's going on
it's got black tar oh it's like somebody
putting the planet Mars right in between
your
between your eyes if we check that we'd
leprechaun right now and that's bone
yard seeds he's running up the out of
Newark ow goddamn he's gettin higher
than a [ __ ] kite
oh he's high as [ __ ] right guard him you
know where he lives think about that
imagine beating your house all day and
not even know you live there think it's
a hotel room thank you here in another
country thinking like man I can't
believe they let me park right in front
of this hotel room this is insane but I
can't believe my dog lives here with me
you know that's where this guy's at bro
he's going deep man
but if he's super deep to be able to go
one nostril out of the side that takes
concentration a lot of reps yeah yeah
that ain't no turn oh this guy is a
veteran dude this guy's a prisoner of
weed bro this guy's been in Viet [ __ ]
name man this guy's been through it all
got that oh that's a Mekong Delta
[ __ ] marijuana smoke right there this
guy is in Da Nang brothers guys killing
Charlie in his brain dude that's gonna
be tough to rip my drip or where the
[ __ ] were joke my smoke my god it's me
tough to beat this one oh this guy dude
all aboard dude he blows out that one
side and people jump on his bag dude all
aboard
this dude is the Noah's Ark of [ __ ]
smoke bro yeah he's so high dude this
guy's property is the best munchies in
his house oh I bet his whole kitchen to
show with dirty ice cream spoons you
know and then just the ends of the bread
yeah just the bags is just the end like
an old spoon and then empty peanut
butter drummers oh I bet he's the kind
of guy who's cut a jar and half of the
knife and [ __ ] heat out of the inside
just to get it all used to get the last
strip of it bro you don't get that high
without doing some crazy stuff in your
[ __ ] kitchen oh dude or to yourself
you know he's trying to toast an egg in
the toaster before this guy is gone
[ __ ] be it looked like it looks like
a high shooting design t-shirts
he obviously has two microwaves you know
because if sometimes you're so high one
microwave they're like [ __ ] man
already got something in that microwave
which had another microwave I said you
mean Totino's [ __ ] have pizza party
which had another Micra to make this
popcorn at the same time so then you get
two microwaves man you could say it has
a full caseload of Capri Sun behind just
drinks those yeah he definitely I mean
hey man he's a smoker man and I
respected dab City man to have it up
shout out to that dude high as [ __ ] so
that does it for this week's joke my
smoke and feel free to send in videos of
you smoking as well and it's time for
King at our sting it the first one from
two ladies hey Brandon hey Theo we love
you guys qinger sting it girls with
glasses
dang it's a big King for me I get that
turns me on sometimes I'm when I'm
watching pornos it'd be like you might
like this and it's like the teacher or
the therapist or someone where the glass
is on the library that's just sexy you
like them glasses you know I'm worried
about though that's for your bangin girl
with glasses
she takes him off that she looks like
the villain from monsters you know the
weird keep guy oh yeah you know like
this isn't sexy yeah like this is chin
this is chin basically yeah he can't see
like that's not sexy he can see you
can't see far like dude sometimes I'll
stand like nine feet from them and like
ring a bell and he doesn't know what's
going on I thinks it's Christmas yeah
like no dude it's just me or it's may
think someone's asking for money it's my
baby bro somebody wrote chill it's
pretty cute man it's cute how he does
that I would say this with the glasses
if you have glasses it means one of two
things you're either smart or you can't
see well and that's you know that's kind
of a that's a risk a man take as if a
woman can't see well she's you know she
needs things she's used to needing
things and not just wanting to be alone
no Dana bad yeah
but then you feel like there's a place
for you cuz a woman be needy you know
like give her like blind women you hug a
blind woman they won't let you go you
know they won't they can't you know I'm
saying well they can but they won't yeah
I don't they can they're just trying to
hang on for dear life no they don't
think it's like a no like an emergency
there's the glass huh
they don't how many people on this earth
has no idea so I hang on for literally
dear a lot how sad is this one time I
wanted to do a business where you made
like a fake Antarctica somewhere okay
and put like a bunch of ice like on a
boat dock and stuff and you had a cruise
of blind people and you took them out of
somewhere and then just brought them
right back to that dock and told them
they were in yeah that's a blast like
Catalina Island like just load them up
blind like hey we're going to this new
place they just discovered yeah yeah and
they think they're in Alaska and it's
Antarctica you get like people to make
whale sounds with horns but really it's
Long Beach yeah yeah it's not that good
of an idea man some problems with that
I still think chicks with glasses are
the way to go it is a bit of a
disability right yeah how bad are their
eyes well you don't want to have
children that can't see especially in a
seeing-eye world like if we lived in a
world where seeing wasn't as important
you know like other you know there's
other countries like that like probably
Africa you don't need to see mmm Africa
dude people are trying to kill each
other all the time so I need to see that
that's a good point yeah yeah so Africa
I know you just follow the rest of the
crowd you need to see yeah China is
actually more of a teamwork yeah it's so
many people just tell you where to go
dude I was in China somebody died right
they made soup out of them like 30
people ate and then everybody just kept
on walking too busy crazy [ __ ] to do
I could barely taste the guy's name bro
like it was like who was he
you gotta make iPhones bro well you just
gotta get it's just all about the next
step it's all about we keep moving out
of time as a people ya know morning you
do that let's go yeah it's not about us
it's about it's not about me it's about
us over there yeah so I say King the
glasses I said King the glass let's
start with the glasses and and let's see
where we go from there
also contacts are annoying I got my oh
dude I take him out right before you're
about to [ __ ] I take my contacts I won't
get dry yeah from 1994 get glasses [ __ ]
or get or get PDK I think that's what is
PDK that's the laser the laser where
they fix your eyes oh wow yeah yeah I
think look didn't make sure your eyes
are working as good as they can and take
them out to the club that's what I do if
you need glasses do glasses if you need
a
- that says this is bad or not that
great do that yeah don't keep it a
secret
yeah don't keep it a secret you don't be
standing around us you know touching
somebody because you don't know where
you're going and they think that you're
hitting on them yeah it's confusing man
they got a me-too problem yeah and next
thing you know it's all because you're
not taking care of your eye health
so keepers yeah I say grab a carrot and
meet a man all right next up coming all
the way from Sydney in Australia from
Nick hand yo what's going on guys Theo
Brennan the boys behind the scenes shout
out to you guys men love the podcast
I'm Nick Haines coming at you from
Sydney Australia and I got a king a
testing a few boys last couple years
I've been getting a bit of love man it's
down to one thing changes are on the
rise brother
so King kind of sting in changes thanks
boys well tear right now most of gingers
I know have this deep darkness inside of
them gang as they call them yeah they
get that that shadow berry fire they hit
the strawberry fire going they had the
fire crotch fire soul oh its mother
they're all good people yeah are you
thinking about all the redheads you know
bill burr Santino yeah that's it
look they're a rare breed you know and
gingers here's what I say yeah love them
support them but are they telling us
everything we don't trust them do we
there's something you're like going on
tell me what you know
because when you see a good ging er
running around or Ginga that's what they
call him over showing off them freckles
yeah it makes you you're like okay look
I support your buddy you know I agree
more sunblock we need more awnings but
also what do you know buddy
what do you know because I don't think
they're just closing everything there's
no way you could have that in you know I
feel like it's a secret among redheads
that we don't know yeah they know
something yeah it's almost like an elite
club yeah it's like Mysterio so conrol
you know that's what they call it in a
lot of Spanish countries in Brazil I
like redheads though oh I look I love
them I support him they quit taking
redheaded semen at the sperm centre a
couple years ago that makes sense nobody
was buying it there was no aftermarket
for it yeah no one really is aiming for
the
well nobody was popping through and say
hey you know Jenny redhead [ __ ] back
here me a couple ounces that [ __ ] red
drip now can I get a ginger like come on
bro yeah give me some of that ginger soy
you know nobody was saying that now so
you know is it something that's gonna
become extinct now that would be great
here's what gingers should do if they
started saying hey we're legally
statistically we are becoming an extinct
species then imagine you get money every
month just for being a dang Ganga like
the goddamn Indians around here well
okay that's one way to put them but yeah
I think some places they're kind of
getting wild I mean any of the native
owners aren't doing anything much man
drinkin and hanging outside of town yeah
I didn't checks cuz we stole their land
yeah [ __ ] up so why not give gingers
but somebody stole everything man we all
stole a somebody stole everything you
know true nobody's just naturally
wandering into a new community and not
[ __ ] stealing that true answer
vultures baby yeah the British stole at
all everybody's everybody's still stolen
everything you know if we want to go
back to the beginning of time
pay us yeah people were killers man Adam
and Eve bro but they had two sons Cain
and Abel one of them killed the other
one four people on earth and one of them
[ __ ] killed one of the other one
preach so we are killers man we are
killers but I'm saying this about the
genghiz bruh don't kill the gingers get
the documentation of your endangered
species and get the money you deserve
yeah be like white rhinos yeah and get
paid bro and then have security around
it cuz you're the last one on North
America yeah they just protect you
because they don't want you to die
imagine that be the white rhino of human
wake up in a cage every morning brother
live your [ __ ] best saliva leaves
think about the futures you guys can
have if you'll get the proper
documentation but no you guys want to
[ __ ] around and do whatever you're doing
and skateboarding and live in Australia
or whatever you say King yet redheads oh
look I'm gonna keep continue to give you
guys a chance but I know you know
something
all right last one for this week's King
at our sting it dude I think Chris
Lilley sent me a DM
unless how does how to dream about that
who's Chris Lilley he did that show
Summer Heights High you ever see that No
you never saw that [ __ ] dude you have to
go watch it you will it's the best show
you'll watch it on you it's on like
YouTube that's a fun on YouTube or
Amazon yeah if you have HBO
what about it's so [ __ ] good bro it's
it's the best show you've never seen
it's only like eight episodes it's so
good what else we got take this ice pack
off boy last one for a king understand
oh [ __ ] what's up this is ashton a
k-state from will be ohio and i got a
king of stinger for yes people make
social media for the pets joe rogan did
it that little ball headed muscle monkey
can you're a sting it gang gang wow dude
what's he doing hello and somebody dude
or or he's doing oral yeah you might be
just doing a pilot light or something
like nick or it looks like use bearing
something it looked pretty shady
probably doing pilot light it's that
time of year and it's also in ohio
inside so people that have separate pets
accounts I always find it weird even
people that have separate kid accounts
that's not posting it when the kid is a
child and infant yeah I don't know what
they want social media and you're
putting that out there for him yes so
Kardashian's so dangerous
tell me about nice Yoona have a 9 year
old fake ears running around about it
yeah next thing you got a 9 year old
with tits well that's a vicious crime
his thing is is those think those
separate pet accounts are a little
strange with Rogan it's different he
doesn't want post his personal [ __ ] so
they started that posting the dog but
most the time when Sona is a separate
pet account it's just there scream yell
for help
yeah I'm saying but also people that
follow those pet accounts all hot
[ __ ] all hot girls so I like to do is
comment like damn cute dog
smiley face yeah oh sweet parrot and the
next you know they're sliding in your
dams you like pears yep you like dick
and that's how it goes now I think that
I mean this and that's the truth a lot
of ladies but also you see in a lot of
these Asian cultures are doping these
animals up on quaaludes and animal can't
even keep their tongue in their mouth
you
they're painting their faces and [ __ ]
yeah and you got a chow you got a Chow
over there that can't chil because he
can't close his mouth
you got a Rottweiler with lipstick on
you no damn without right well you got a
Rottweiler the King Wyler you know and
they're doing that kind of [ __ ] because
they're putting ludes ands and bars into
these [ __ ] childs and Pomerania yeah
the Bulldog who can't bull yeah you got
a shar-pei that can't that ain't very
char you know look at that that supposed
to be a sharp pain right there click on
the main picture right there
that's a sharp blade is sharp a the face
limit yeah we got Sharpay with a
facelift yep we got the Sharpay after
those ludes are on look at it looks like
a damn beagle look at his tongue yeah
Warner College came running around the
border look at that other one get the
tongue hang out that white one yeah big
whitey looking damn he got that dick
tongue good but that's what somehow he
grew a full man's [ __ ] out of his mouth
dude that's what happens when you're
feeding this shitty dog food that's not
Singapore shar-pei where they put him on
the him on zan bars for a couple months
he was doing the circuit is one of those
you know Baba you know beautiful you
know Instagram animals and look at him
now
now he's in a halfway house somewhere
outside of Sipe a/c and then someone's
gonna start a separate account me like
look at my dogs hung a hashtag cute
hashtag long hashtag dry hashtag cocked
um and then there you got a picture
every Wednesday I have this [ __ ] dog
yeah I mean it's a cry for help I'm
telling him he's got my friend post a
picture with your friend how about that
he looks like Bernie Sanders to a little
bit man if you start to look at him he
does that's time strolls by and looks
like right now I'm saying right now I
bet two weeks until Hillary Clinton
announces that she's running for
president again watch two weeks bro and
I'm happy to be wrong but I just bet
very similar-looking very soon do look
similar
got his I bet base berry berries nuts
look like his tongue look at the end of
his tongue I can't even imagine he's
nuts very similar so I'm saying after
these ludes these animals look like
politicians and they got these animals
on lose yeah when you say lose I think
it's nyquil I'm sick of that [ __ ] like
you you turn on Discovery Channel
they're catching these wild animals and
they get to them they like X you're
sleepy you're not fooling nobody
yeah you pop a cup of those night quails
and we're expecting that you just
strolled upon this thing ain't nobody
buying it man yeah Deadliest Catch we
know you're out there all night you know
pouring [ __ ] dimetapp off the back of
the ship yeah a bit you know TZ to catch
these [ __ ] uh these red sea bass when
they all you know barely await Rousey
and they think they have a call catch
them in a nap yeah you can get a call
funder water idiot stupids let's see
what's next
that does it for this week's king under
sting it and the finale segment we've
got flaunt my aunt the first ones coming
from Brennan it's his mega aunt Megan
she's 38 years old from upstate New York
damn girls she looks like she just got
done with Woodcock dang dudes huh that's
Trey it looks like Trey Anastasio bro
god damn she looks like the biggest fan
of Aerosmith oh dude she looks like
widespread actually started panicking
she looks like she'll tell you a story
about when she sucked off Axl Rose in
the 70s that would be the late 80s early
90s dude no no he's a kid oh really yeah
sober sex is for children yeah let's use
a kid I love this are too old for that
bro this Marley and me shout out in the
back and yeah what I love about the dog
is that he knows that uh he doesn't that
smoking is not for him yeah he's too far
away from it I like how she's wearing a
full-body suit of tie-dyed I don't know
where the [ __ ] you get that besides San
Francisco yeah but she looks sexy man
she's got some heaters under that uh you
know she looks like the Weather Channel
[ __ ] decided to go to a rave if you
look at that it's like Doppler radar
made an outfit she looks like Miss
Doppler yeah but definitely look I like
that and I'm mad at the swag at all she
looks like she's talking about the time
she tripped her ass off acid you know
I'm saying yeah she has some great drug
story oh it looks like if you took off
the sweater and took off the jean shorts
she would just be ready to you know like
she'd be at a slumber party and um at
John bells house and I think John bells
elite singer wise we're panning it could
be wrong who is it
mmm I don't know let's look him up she
looks like she's like she lives in gene
Simmons house
John Bell good bro thanks dude don't
[ __ ] touch one touch mean that
special dude during this man ERISA
especially of the black line yeah well
you touched me you idiot alright what
else we got shut up to this fine-ass
beautiful lady though doing to Milo the
fact that she likes going outdoors and
likes listening to music and doing a
little bit uh yeah Nicole sent him like
she whatever cheese she was like you
might have a child soon you know she's
seven no she's got a dog while listening
to Red Hot Chili Peppers what else you
got
Nicole sent in her Uncle John okay he's
Uncle John a serial killer Uncle John
Wayne Gacy breath this is John Wayne gay
gay dude
like John Wayne Gacy John Wayne is gay
see there yeah he looks like he's
wearing that necklace yet too if you
look at him he got that necklace yet
going across his torso
it looks like he's at a toga party and
he looks like he's at a toga party at
Edgar Allan Poe's house
it looks like he's one bad fart away
from snapping on everybody chilling the
entire room looks like well it looks
like maybe he like fell asleep smoke and
burned the rest of his off and this is
what he's got but he seems like a nice
guy you know he's doing good stuff he's
got the pearls on he's doing good stuff
though yeah or he fell asleep in his
buddies pranked the [ __ ] out and put him
in a dress that's what might've happened
he has on two pairs of panties yeah
you're right yeah yeah rarely do you do
the double panty unless you're going
through some stuff you know unless it's
like but no stuff you mean acid and he
might be doing menopause and who knows a
lot of men are doing wild stuff and if
he's doing menopause then bright you
know god bless him shut up to those
pearls around his neck too and I've
learned real pearls then I am very
impressed jealous
yeah shiny do a white face though he's
illegal dude that is frowned upon
that's John Wayne gay baby and he's
doing blue eyes which Smurfs are
gonna get offended at when you got the
cholo eyebrows okay way to [ __ ] call
them out yup and easy also got the red
cheeks with cheeks yep he's trying to
offend everybody yeah and he's doing a
good job man you look beautiful John
Wayne gay alright and the last one for
flaw my aunt this is coming all the way
from South Wales in the United Kingdom
sent in by Barry okay
great aunt Pam Joe let me tell you some
you're crazy if you don't think she's
racist
she gives up you're crazy aunty she
drops an N bomb every three seconds in
her household brother they don't have in
bombs in the UK she has all the bombs
really oh yeah sure like anybody unless
you're white no I think she seems like
an upstanding member of the community
she seems like she doesn't travel okay
I'll say that but I doesn't travel mean
doesn't never left that bed yeah that's
a chair that's her bed [ __ ] good call
she has a wedding ring on so she
obviously knows how to get it and that
gun she's waiting for you to step on her
lawn that's yellow
that's that William Wallace hit her the
thing is he's running around with
brother that's that bad that's that
[ __ ] Elmer Fudd shotgun brother
that's that bad stick a Roman candy and
she'll [ __ ] send you back into the
Trojan horse dog so if I can light you
up with that peace do you'd [ __ ]
ding-dong-ditch her she's gonna shoot
you in the back a racial slur I bet if
you shoot a gun just racial slurs you
buy out of it
Wow but she section me makes a mean
apple pie
oh yeah and she looks like she cooked it
with fire with uh with a firearm one one
arm on the firearm ya know like she
actually shoots it to be a room temp you
know like she puts all the ingredients
into a potato she lasted him dude she
look at it she looks pissed it sounds
that hey what do you think Obama she
just like snapped the pic if she's
pissed cuz brexit keeps stolen they keep
stolen brexit they keep pushing it back
another couple weeks and now they say
they might move the votes of two years
from their wedding the [ __ ] are we
talking about she does not look happy
she's tio dude and she her vote counts
man someone better dinner
damn carrot juice stat oh dude carrot
bro you better drip a little [ __ ] bit
back splash for proving into that
[ __ ] yeah yeah orange water yeah he
seems beautiful she's an adult hopefully
she's doing stuff at the community
centre maybe some square dancing you
know to get out around the house yeah
she just needs to get out but thanks for
sharing her with us bud and God bless
her god bless velcro shoes that does it
for this week's flaw my odd that's
pretty much all the segments except it's
time for people to get inspired why
don't we do start my heart oh yeah
this week's start my heart mutual friend
or acquaintance of ours
Andrew Schultz he's a comedian from the
East Coast he does the brilliant idiots
with Charlemagne and his stories
inspiring because he releases his
special just on his own you went all the
big networks don't wanna pick me up
check this out so he's really sitting
just big bits of his special on his
YouTube he's doing the damn thing he's
out here right now in LA I think is you
want on my show and yours this week and
then he's also at the comedy story a
shows all over he's just hustling man he
saw cent doing his way he's a great
podcast called brilliant idiots yeah and
he's one guy that honestly I never
wanted to follow in a comedy club man
cuz I monster dude he is a yeah he is
he's the Ted Bundy man he is a monster
man he's a killer
he is a comedian yep and um so y'all
here in LA this week's nice lady thing
he just used my studio to do his podcast
last night so shout out to Andrew
Schultz oh nice alright and for mine
this week I'm gonna go with Sebastian
Maniscalco he was an actor he's comedian
but he's an actor in the green book that
won Best Picture correct I believe and
so it's inspiring to see you know
Sebastian didn't get any acclaim for
years really from the industry and so he
really would had to go out and earn it
himself did you see him at the Oscars
yes on the red carpet yeah I know it's
so cool and also it's so funny I was
following on Instagram saying how he had
to sit in the third floor he was in a
third floor level but he's not a star of
the movie you know he's a he's a he's a
character in the movie but still just
amazing to see him even go through that
as a comedian like this isn't acting is
not
first job it's not his primary goal and
this is just something that he got to be
a part of but uh very inspiring and just
cool to see him go through that
experience and and he always seems to be
the same person no matter what he's one
of the good guys he's one of the good
guys and and I think both of those guys
are this guys that have had to earn it
and I work hard and I think it would be
almost ill for us not to say this I
think both our start my heart should
probably Brody Stephens though as a
mutual start my heart that's a good
point
probably Brody Stephens as well there's
me a bonus one this week yeah Brody
Stephens what's your best memory of
Brody Stephens my best memory of Brody
Stephens it's probably just watching him
on stage which every time kind of almost
runs together you know he would always
kind of do the same thing of just
getting the audience his crowd work yeah
his crowd work and it didn't matter if
they were on his side or not on his side
sometimes the whole set nobody would get
what he was doing but he would still do
it but he would still do it
Howard through it yeah just the
senseless commitment to himself and to
Burgess positive energy man he oh that's
all he ever talked about it was positive
energy he just always talked about it I
didn't realize I think a lot of times he
was talking about because he needed it
you know he needed it self no idea I had
no idea so yeah good call man start my
heart to Brody Stephens man miss you but
you know love you man I think that's it
let's close on that brother that's it
dude get better man get back will you
get better oh I'm well I'm healthy right
now I spent healthy I mean just wolf I
think you have to get better bro yeah
get better I will be at Miami improv
Miami improv this March new Club Miami
improv new Club a little nervous about
it I bet then we just added Milwaukee
paps theater nice Milwaukee nice man in
DC all in March 2nd 3rd and 4th week of
March I'm back on the road and the bde
tour starts March really new tour new
tour
it's exciting man I know I'm excited and
I'll see you guys I'll be at the cheval
year theater uh March 6th or 7th I think
in Medford Boston Massachusetts you can
still get tickets online and some of the
barstool guys will be there it's gonna
be interesting thank you guys so much
love it love it
[Music]